Today, a star fell.
It was almost like...
Like seeing something out of a dream,...
...nothing more or less than a breathtaking view.
Want to hit the cafe later?
Thanks, but I got to go to work.
I can't stand this place anymore.
It's too small and towny.
Please make me a handsome Tokyo boy in my next life!
Where?
Now that you mention it, I do feel like I've been having weird dreams lately.
I could dream about someone else's life?
What is this?
Could this mean?
In our dreams, that girl and I...
We're switching places?
There's one thing I'm certain of.
If we see each other, we'll definitely know right away.
I was planning to tell you that wherever you are in the world,...
...I swear that I'll find you again no matter what.
Who are you?
Can I ask you your name?